12h13 la première
[Musique]
je vous souhaite la bienvenue dans face
à la première en ce dimanche 17 janvier
pour un nouveau numéro de notre émission
politique hebdomadaire
les missions proposées par la rédaction
de martinique la première quelle forme
doit prendre la relance de notre
économie mise en péril comme ailleurs
d'ailleurs par la pandémie provoquée par
le virus du comité 19
s'agit-il d'une relance ou faut-il
parler plutôt d'une refonte du tissu
économique martiniquais en quoi la ctm
peut-elle contribuer à l'atténuation des
effets de cette crise sanitaire que sont
l'augmentation du chômage les fermetures
d'entreprises le ralentissement de la
consommation
la baisse du pouvoir d'achat ou encore
le report des investissements publics et
privés
je vous propose de passer en revue ses
différentes questions avec deux élus de
la collectivité territoriale de
martinique
cela dans le cadre de notre série
d'émissions sur le bilan et les
perspectives de l'institution nos
invités à cette émission sont tout
d'abord marine est trempée bonjour
madame temps pays dont sûr mais c'est
parti et bonjour aux auditeurs et
auditrices tu maintiens que la première
je rappelle que vous êtes membre du
conseil exécutif de la collectivité
territoriale de martinique chargé du
développement économique de l'aide aux
entreprises et à l'emploi
vous êtes militant du mouvement bas pays
en chasse présidée par également plaisir
implantée à schoelcher où nous est
d'ailleurs conseillère municipale de
l'opposition dans un mandat président
vous avez été adjointe au maire de
l'ancien maire alfred almont et vous
exercez pour terminer cette brève
présentation la profession de courtier
en assurances a tout à fait à côté de
vous j'ai un autre chef d'entreprise en
la personne de daniel robin bonjour
mathieu robail chez party bonjour et
bonjour à tous nos compatriotes et
meilleurs voeux de bonne et heureuse
année
merci monsieur robin conseiller à
l'assemblée de lentilles nick vous êtes
élu de l'opposition dans la coalition
ensemble pour une martinique nouvelle
vous êtes ancien membre du ppe le parti
progressiste martiniquais
vous êtes chef d'entreprise comme je le
disais tout à l'heure mais dans le
secteur des économies d'énergie peut
être aurons nous l'occasion d'en parler
tout à l'heure j'ai le plaisir de vous
recevoir aujourd'hui pour cette émission
réalisée par patrice allagui sans la
chine et rodrigue calix tout d'abord
premières questions d'actualité
dans nos dernières mesures contre la
crise sanitaire prises à l'échelle du
territoire hexagonal de la france couvre
feu à 18 heures partout quelle que soit
la circulation du virus
qu'est ce que vous en dites que ça vous
en pensez madame monsieur marriner tant
pis
écoutez c'est vrai qu'on n'est
aujourd'hui les politiques et notamment
donc le gouvernement se trouve dans des
positions délicates où il faut faire la
part des choses entre maintenir une
activité maintenir une circulation et de
la population et des des biens des
marchandises et puis il y à cette
pandémie il faut faire face et prendre
des mesures de restriction est
normalement et aussi donc de restriction
de circulation
donc on chaque fois il faut regarder les
chiffres vous avez effectivement le le
comité de surveillance qui donne des
avis et gnamien l'époux de mont joli
sens tout à fait tout à fait derrière
les politiques doivent prendre des
décisions
et alors c'est vrai tout un chacun et
même moi on peut commenter la décision
disant est ce que il faut vraiment fait
recette faire un confinement ou faire un
couvre-feu
aujourd'hui ce couvre feu généralisé à
18 heures pour tout le monde quels que
soient les régions de l'hexagone
s'explique puisque ils ont quand même
expliqué que laval la nouvelle variante
du virus est traîtresse ce coup de se
propage à une vitesse où il faut arrêter
donc cette circulation du virus donc
arabe stopper un peu donc les
déplacements de foot personne ça
s'explique
mais c'est très difficile aujourd'hui
les gens arrivent un peu je dirais un
peu à bout et ils n'arrivent pas à même
de façon je dirais responsable ils ont
du mal à vouloir restreindre leur
liberté
et effectivement on est aujourd'hui à se
poser la question est ce qu'on fait bien
ou pas bien je dis c'est après qu'on
pourra dire mais il faut faire quelque
chose de toutes les façons on ne peut
pas rester sans rien faire je terminais
dessus les pays qui n'ont rien fait dès
le départ ou pas pris de mesures très
fortes dès le départ se trouve
aujourd'hui en grande difficulté
sanitaires prises après la suède en
europe ou encore fait les états unis
voir le brésil dans une autre mine dans
une moindre mesure daniel robert
faudrait-il fallait-il instauré le
couvre feu hier à 18h ici en martinique
très m'exonérer clairement non enfin je
n'étais pas du tout partisan de ce type
de mesures pour la martinique
comme je ne sais pas d'ailleurs très fan
de la mesure de confinement que nous
avons vécu au mois de novembre
pourquoi d'abord il ya une réalité à
laquelle nous sommes exposés c'est qu'
il est très difficile de faire la preuve
que ce les mesures qui sont prises ou un
impact direct sur ce que nous constatons
je prends l'exemple de ce qui s'est
passé au niveau national ou le
confinement donc de la fin de l'année et
est assujetti dans un cadre dit de
visibilité par le président de la
république d'une d'un objectif
bon c'était donc le fameux objectifs des
5000 cas positifs
merci comme on n'est jamais arrivé
malgré tout on s'attendait à ce qu'il y
ait donc des mesures qu'ils soient
prises et finalement il ya eu ce double
est double détente donc effectivement
confinement 20h petit grâce je lirai pas
la période de noël pour le 31 décembre
ça a été quelque chose donc de d'un peu
plus conforme à ce qui était déjà posée
mais aujourd'hui et c'est ça qui me qui
m'interpelle il ya des mesures pour ce
qui concerne la martinique qui n'ont pas
été comprises et je crois qu'il ya un
très grave déficit de communication et
surtout que je prends un exemple celui
des étudiants ou au niveau national il y
avait une date qui était posée pour que
l'on puisse progressivement assister à
la réouverture des universités
ici il ya eu des mouvements notamment
avec la femme l'association lazem là qui
s'est mobilisée et je nous ne comprenons
pas feint de gamme en tant qu'élu je ne
comprends pas parce que j'étais
directement interpellé la ctm l'a été
nous avons tous unanimement pris une
position en faveur de l'ouverture
réouverture de l'eau de l'université et
ça a tardé et une fois de plus il faut
que ce soit une mesure sortie de paris
qui permettent à la martinique de
respirer donc dans tout cela je pense
qu'il ya franchement pour moi deux
niveaux il ya le fait de dire ok nous
sommes bien évidemment dans un espace
national mais que les réalités de
différenciation doivent être en
permanence celle qui guide et président
aux décisions et ce n'est pas le cas
marina torpille est ce que vous
acquiescez à l'idée selon laquelle
l'état ici le préfet le directeur de
l'agencé régionale de santé sont trop
visibles prennent trop de décisions
à l'inversé de ce que souhaitent les
élus ou en faisant semblant d'avoir une
concertation comme certains élus l'ont
dénoncé l'on déploré comme quoi c'est
l'état qui a repris la meo qui a pris la
main depuis le départ malgré les
protestations et d'alfred marie jeanne
et de francis carole pour par glacé tm
une brise et de l'association des maires
ou d'autres élus qui se plaignent de
ceux qui ne sont pas suffisamment
entendue par les autorités et qui au
contraire s'il était peut-être que des
mesures ont été mieux expliquer mieux
comprises et mieux impliquée
alors que l'état prenne la main c'est
quand même le rôle de l'état d'organiser
je dirais la la santé publique et le
métier d'une de d'un environnement
sanitaires convenables sur un territoire
mais par contre qu'il y ait cette
concertation
moi personnellement ce que je
reprocherais c'est qu' il n'y a pas eu
assez de différenciation comme a dit le
collègue robin il n'y a pas eu assez de
2,2
je dirais de de personnalisation à la
martinique des mesures qui ont été
prises enfin kocak fin qu'on avait des
mesures ce sont des mesures qui ont été
prises et qui ont été portées par le
ministre de l'outre-mer qui nous ont été
appliquées aux je prends simplement
comme comme exemple le problème des des
églises et et moi je les dis on ne peut
pas être on n'était pas à un taux de
contamination importante on n'avait pas
une réanimation qui était jeudi reçu au
bouquet et n'empêche on vous dit que on
ne rompt ne revint pas les églises et
quand on a pu permettre qu'elles seront
verte pour faire la messe était pas plus
de 30 personnes c'est une décision qui
était totalement ridicule pour notre
territoire
et je les dis et là monsieur le préfet
n'a pas voulu nous entendre et c'est
dommage parce que ça permet d'éviter des
frustrations ça permet d'éviter des
incompréhensions lors de l'assaut
plusieurs petites mesures comme ça où on
n'est pas entendu après je dirais on
perd en légitimité
et c'est ce qui se passe quand on verra
ce carnaval c'est vrai que moi je suis
pas je suis personnellement pas pour
qu'il y ait le carnaval parce que je
pense que ce sera un facteur qui sera
effectivement qui s'en dédit de meetic
qui va nous mettre une peut-être une
épidémie plus forte et donc mais
aujourd'hui avec toutes les mesures
qu'on a prises qui était simplement
calquer à celle de la région parisienne
eh bien on a je pense qu'on a perdu un
peu de pertinence dans les mesures qu'on
aurait pu faire localement société ça ne
s'applique pas qu'à la martinique oil
autrement puisque l'un dans l'hexagone
les blessures des élus de marseille des
élus de la bretagne il ya deux niveaux
sur lesquels font ce que je souhaite
réagir le premier quand même c'est que
il y a eu des élus qui ont été en
contact avec le préfet qui ont fait des
réunions alors je sais qu'il y avait
plusieurs niveaux de réunion mais quand
bien même
j'ai été très surpris puisque j'ai fait
partie d'une de ses réunions et j'ai
constaté que finalement il ya des
discours qui étaient tenus dans le
secret du bureau du préfet qui n'était
pas le discours qu'ils étaient tenus
publiquement publiquement et les
martiniquais l'ont bien compris et bien
entendu donc je pense qu'il faut arrêter
là aussi d'être dans ces doubles
discours est d'être dans la posture est
l'autre sujet qui m'a qui m'a vraiment
interpellé lorsque j'ai vraiment scruter
regarder avec acuité tout ce qui s'est
passé je pense qu'il ya une capacité
d'initiative et même peut-être parfois
de désobéissance c'est à dire que les
premiers maires qui ont pris des mesures
offensives pour protéger leurs
populations
sap a été en martinique ça a été à sosa
était à nice ça a été en bretagne
donc je pense qu'à un moment donné aussi
il faut se rappeler que nous avons la
possibilité d'être jeudi le marronnage
dont on parle tant
finalement il n'est pas si usité que
cela est appliqué mais je pense qu'il
faut savoir ce qu'on veut et il faut
savoir a affirmé la réalité de ce que
nous sommes nous sommes différents nous
sommes sur une île nous avons la
capacité à être des responsables d'une
politique locale
donc nous avons à coeur de nous engager
et je pense que c'est ça la réalité
plutôt que de se tourner vers l'état où
le maire ou les ministres arrivons
ensemble entre martiniquais à déterminer
ce qui est le bon cap
et ce qui est nécessaire de faire et
malheureusement je crois que la
situation de crise que nous avons vécue
et que nous vivons encore n'a pas été le
témoignage de cette attente forte car il
est en pin sur une autre chapitre nous
reviendrons tout allait aussi le rôle de
la septième de cette crise sanitaire
les élections ont des chances d'être
reporté de massage et enfin c'est déjà
acté le gouvernement souhaite leur
portée les reporters jeu même si c'est
le parlement qui décide il faudra que le
sénat compte du 25 janvier puis
l'assemblée nationale le décide il y
aura encore le couperet du conseil
scientifique nationale qui doit prendre
qui doit donner un avis de 10 avril pour
savoir si oui ou non il est faisable et
légitime d'organiser l'élection mois de
jeu est ce que ça vous inquiète est ce
que ça vous perturbe le fait que ce
mandat soit prolongé comme ça sans date
de fin de jeu de fin de contrat à durée
déterminée s'est lui dit voilà alors
juste avant pour répondre avant de
répondre à votre question je veux dire
quand même moi je parle je ne partage
pas l'idée de marronnage de
désobéissance parce que je pense qu'on
peut avoir des dérives après on commence
à aller vers généré sur des chemins et
après on n'arrive plus à ce soit mais
comment dg mark hurd est instruit c'est
à notre portée
s'ils n'ont pas fait ça ce sont des
formations politiques qui comptent et
louise et le marronnage oui oui je sais
qu'ils font partie de votre
et que là c'était commandes des masques
commandés test s'impliquent y compris
dans la question de la vaccination pour
ceux qui sont responsables soient
responsables et qu'on soit là c'est moi
qui suis d'accord alors concernant donc
vous des élections bon déjà nous sommes
pas encore en dépassement de mandat
c'était nous étions élus pour six ans
donc à la fin de 2021 nous hâtons nous
atteindrons la nôtre sixième année c'est
quand même perturbant puisqu'à un moment
vous dit ces cités on est en mars
maintenant c'est prévu enfin pressenti
en juin peut-être page 1 à cause donc de
la situation sanitaire
la housse et c'est un peu dérangeant
c'est que vous savez qu avant les
élections vous avez six mois deux de
réserve électorale donc vous ne pouvez
pas faire tout ce que vous avez à faire
ou dire tout ce que vous avez dire dans
les mêmes conditions que s'il n'y a pas
d'élection c'est le budget de la
collectivité des actions de promotion de
il ya des effectifs et moi je pense
avoir l'occasion de vous parler du salon
aux le salon le rendez-vous des
entrepreneurs confirmés mars
il ya malgré que c'est récurrent donc je
n'ai pas trop de problème de réserves
sur cet événement mais il ya d'autres
événements qu'on voudrait faire donc bon
donc ça peut être perturbant
ceci dit et puis généralement on aime
bien savoir que notamment sur un
événement si important qu'une élection
ça se passe à telle date et on se
prépare à plus qu'à la campagne à feria
il ya des dispositions à prendre donc
c'est vrai que c'est d'une façon ou
d'une autre c'est dérangeant
donc il faudrait il faudrait vraiment
qu'à un moment donné qu'on sache
exactement
effectivement si c'est en avril qu'on
décide que ce sera je deux mois trois
mois avant
cc je pense que c'est même c'est pas
tenable que qu'on arrive qu'on nous dit
c'est pour juin bon c'est vrai que je
peux comprendre qu'on compte que la date
dépend de la situation sanitaire tout ça
il faudrait qu'on fasse avec bon déjà
jurénil ex une campagne ce n'est pas
simple ça ça complique la situation ça
vous déstabilise à vous dérange
en baisse ce terme qui n'est pas défini
de votre mandat moi je suis assez
pragmatique sur ces situations à ce que
je constate c'est que il y a un un
contexte qui a été créée socio
psychologique qui fait que d'abord il ya
une certaine réalité anxiogène voilà qui
fait que le rapport à l'autre le rapport
aux personnes et dans notre réalité
politique qui a souvent la b6 et de pour
faire campagne
réunir des gens et et rencontrer des
personnes c'est extrêmement difficile
si on veut rester dans un cadre de la
stricte conformité par rapport à ce qui
a été posée ensuite comme le disait donc
marié tant pis bon à force de
contorsionner de tordre la règle on
oublie que en fait l'élection de mars ou
de juin raccourci le mandat des élus
parce qu'en fait la réalité c'est que
nous notre mandat court normalement
puisque jusqu'à la fin de la limmat est
donc maintenant qu'il puisse y avoir un
élément d'anticipation pourquoi pas mais
ce qui est dommageable mais c'est le
contexte ces cas pas de visibilité donc
et que nous savons très bien que il
n'est pas envisageable de reproduire ce
qui s'est passé l'année dernière pour
les municipales parce que on ne peut pas
dire aux personnes
restez chez vous et puis en même temps
on leur dit allez voter donc il faut
rester cohérent et ceci nécessite
peut-être qu'il y ait alors j'ai entendu
beaucoup de déclarations de deux
politiques locaux y compris le président
du conseil exécutif dire qu'il a obtenu
le report au mois de juin
bon voyons ce que ça va donner mais moi
ce que je pense c'est que dans ce
domaine comme dans d'autres
soyons dans un principe de précaution la
politique ne supplante pahlavi donc la
priorité c'est la vie je ne vois pas qui
pourrait france à obtenir leur projet
puisque c'est le parlement qui va
décider bon ça ces questions d'ordre
institutionnel alors pour revenir à la
gestion de la crise sanitaire marinette
tant pis je me retourne vers vous mais
daniel robin sera sollicité également
avec cette question comment utiliser à
bon escient le plus efficacement
possible
les saumons j'allais dire très
importante que la septième a prévu
d'injecter dans le circuit économique en
général nous avons totalement quelques
précisions quelques détails je rappelle
qu'un budget supplémentaire de 265
millions d'euros a été votée dans 210
millions d'euros d'emprunts pour
soutenir l'économie qui lie à deuxième
budget supplémentaire de 26 millions
d'euros
et puis troisième chiffres on est patron
pas gagné mais aux auditeurs un terrain
et internautes 80 millions d'euros ont
d'ores et déjà été accordée par la 7e je
parle sous notre contrôle aux
entreprises martiniquaises depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire beh laquelle
quelle est la priorité pour vous qui
vous occupez de les deux entreprises le
dal endroit pour affronter les effets de
cette crise sanitaire
alors c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des budgets
supplémentaires mais il ya eu aussi des
fonds qui n'ont pas encore été mobilisés
par la ctm ça c'est encore je dirais une
autre affaire ceci dit me concernant sur
l'aide aux entreprises nous avons
effectivement mobilisé plus de 80
millions d'euros pour pouvoir soutenir
les entreprises et je tiens à dire que
j'ai personnellement été à la manoeuvre
parce qu' il fallait que l'on trouve
après le premier confinement on a on
s'est réunis j'ai réuni donc au niveau
des services de la 7e il ya eu aussi des
réunions qui ont été faites avec la
commission de développement économique
et tourisme donc présidé par yan
monplaisir
on a fait des commissions commune avec
les autres
des réunions communes avec les autres
commissions pour pouvoir valider sortir
des idées mais aussi valider les idées
qui était sorti et il ya eu vraiment un
travail entre - la conseillère exécutive
et les services
et cette commission pour qu'on puisse
sortir des dispositifs ces dispositifs
ont été amendés des fois par l'assemblée
et ils ont été mis en place et ses 80
millions
tout était donc où on a pu aider
effectivement des entreprises qui est
qui subissait une perte de chiffre
d'affaires importantes ou et là sur le
deuxième dispositif aussi sur les
entreprises qui ont été obligés de
fermer et les entreprises de tourisme
elles ont trouvé
dans les dispositifs que nous avons
prévu que nous avons donc validé que
nous avons mis en oeuvre l on trouve à
un soutien qui est efficace
le seul jeudi l'as la seule région de
d'outre-mer à l'avoir mis en place et
concernant le deuxième dispositif
nous avons été pratiquement la seule
région de france je sais pas pour
l'ile-de-france mais d'avoir mis en
place ce dispositif
et c'est tellement vrai que c était
important quand on regarde les chiffres
de l'insee aujourd'hui on vous dit que
au niveau de la martinique nous avons
pas eu l'effondrement de notre système
économique
parce que nous avons vraiment soutenu la
petite entreprise
et c'est là où je pense que nous avons
vraiment joué notre rôle et je suis très
assez fier quand même parce que j'étais
tellement je dirais sûr sûr sûr sûr
c'est projet de dispositif
et puis sur la transformation numérique
peut être aura l'occasion d'en parler
là aussi nous avons nous avons pu avoir
des réactions fortes
daniel roubaix même question pour vous
vous êtes dans l'opposition à la 7ème et
même si vous avez parfois l'occasion à
voter dans le censeur ou préconisées par
la majorité mais souvent aussi contre
puisque tout n'est pas aussi me réjouis
aussi consensuel en matière de soutien à
l'économie
qu'est ce que vous reprochez oriella
maintenant puisque la crise n'est pas
terminée la crise économique encore mais
ce qu'est ce qui vous j'aimerais dans
l'action la cité en faveur du soutien à
l'économie alors d'abord je ne voudrais
pas qu'on limite l'action de la cité
elle dans cette réalité de crise
sanitaire à la saint-loup simple soutien
à l'économie au niveau
franchement je pense que je pense que
c'est important que martiniquaise elle
indiqué sachez aussi qu'il y a eu sur le
volet donc sociale l'accompagnement
notamment des plus faibles des personnes
âgées des mesures qui ont été développés
donc cependant pour répondre à votre
question je crois qu'il ya un enjeu qui
est toujours d'actualité c'est la
préservation de l'activité et la
préservation de l'emploi
ce que je sais à date c'est qu'on ne
peut pas encore dire que la martinique
s'en sort mieux que d'autres
pourquoi nous avons un indicateur qui
est celui du nombre de dépôts de bilan
et qu'il faut savoir quand même que cet
indicateur n'est pas suivie depuis
quelques mois parce que il y a eu une
réalité de non fonctionnement de
l'activité judiciaire comme elle le
devait donc nous allons découvrir dans
quelques jours la réalité de ce que la
crise a produit quand même par rapport
aux dossiers qui étaient déposés au
tribunal avant le mois de mars il y a eu
dans la période
une vraiment une réalité quasi
systématique
ce sont des liquidations pas de
redressement des liquidation pure et
simple des faillites pour parler
français
voilà facile des faillites des
entreprises qui ont disparu et les
emplois qui étaient attachés ont disparu
donc pour moi il ya eu deux temps dans
la proche du soutien à l'économie il ya
le volet 1 du plan de la ctm sur lequel
nous avons été je crois très en
propositions l'opposition a vraiment été
en propositions pour amender améliorer
et faire en sorte qu'il y ait une
meilleure couverture possible de
l'accompagnement aux entreprises de quoi
il était question est sûre ça je je
rends hommage à ce qui a été fait il y
avait des problèmes sur la période de
référence par rapport à la baisse du
chiffre d'affaires il y avait une
réalité d'une de niveau des deux le
montant des aides
il y avait aussi des réalités
d'entreprise qui se retrouvaient un
petit peu en dehors de tous les
dispositifs donc le premier temps était
pour nous un temps de critiques
positives et constructives pour
améliorer l'existant et donc il ya eu
une nouvelle réunion de l'assemblée et à
l'occasion de cette réunion les
dispositifs ont été améliorés bon sans
être sans être pour autant totalement
satisfaisant c'est cependant
il y a eu quand même deux choses que
nous avons noté entre le moment où les
délibérations ont été prises et le
moment où elle était effective le temps
passer a été trop long parce que cinq
mois à peu près entre les délibérations
et le moment où les entreprises ont
commencé à pouvoir accéder avec des
lourdeurs techniques et parfois un peu
administrative sur des choix qui ont été
faits voilà donc nous pensons que
globalement et voyez jeu on peut être
dans l'opposition
et quand on est entendu on fait bouger
les choses mais il fallait aller
certainement un tout petit peu plus loin
le deuxième volet de ce point de vue là
par rapport aux non essentiels ne prend
pas en compte pas plus que le premier
une dimension clé c'est la question des
loyers puisque aujourd'hui parmi les
charges fixes des entreprises sur lequel
il faut agir pour pouvoir mieux passer
le cap
il ya la question de la prise en charge
des loyers il ya eu des directives au
niveau national qui ont été données mais
pas de relais l'autre chose et j'ai été
auditionné dans certaines communes et
agglomérations alors pour être quant au
président sortant ont pris des mesures
prises des mesures sont tenir quelques
autres en tout cas activement la paix
mondiale reason n'a pas été généralisé
sur tout le territoire
un autre sujet et dans la crise des de
la fin de l'année savez j'ai été
interpellé par beaucoup d'entreprises
qui disait la chose suivante c'est bien
effectivement d'avoir identifié les non
essentiels mais ceux qui sont totalement
corrélée dans leurs activités dont
l'activité dépend d'un certain nombre de
secteurs de l'hôtellerie le tourisme
quand vous êtes fournisseur d'un hôtel
vous avez une ou d'hôtels ou de
restaurants vous êtes dans une
difficulté majeure qui n'est pas
imputable à votre activité nos contextes
la liste des entreprises prise en charge
n'intégrait pas celle ci c'est
dommageable quand on dit à des
restaurateurs vous pouvez faire de
l'emporter mais qu'il y a des structures
dont c'est le métier du premier danse
décembre au 31 janvier qui se retrouvent
concurrence et elles ont mécaniquement
une baisse de leur chiffre d'affaires
et elles ne sont pas visés parce
qu'elles ne sont pas dans les fameuses
listes dont je pense qu'une réalité de
souplesse a créé pour être plus
efficient pertinent et avoir donc la
possibilité d'être
plus un impact sur l'économie face à la
première
ce sont des observations des suggestions
que vous entendez dans la majorité
oui mais ça tout à fait mais non mais il
a fallu faire enfin je pourrais lui dire
ou pas d'hier mais enfin s'il a fallu
faire des choix donc quand on fait des
choix c'est sûr que non mais on a eu
aussi des retours il ya dernièrement un
grossiste en textile et m'a dit oui mais
madame comprenez que tous mes clients
ils étaient fermés puisqu'il était en
commun sont essentiels il ya eu des
choix il fallait on n'a pas pu tout
prendre bon donc on a fait et encore on
a ses suites sais pas si tu te rappelles
daniel quand j'avais dans une réunion
vraiment parler sur les restaurants
qu'il fallait maintenir ouvrir ouvert et
tout est donc déjà c'était une demande
pourquoi les restaurants étaient fermés
chez nous c'est une demande et en plus
de ça ça a été que nous avons pensé
ouvrir le les touristes parce que les
structures du tourisme il fallait qu'ils
n'étaient pas dans tout en essentiel
qu'il fallait quand même leur permettre
de d'avoir une indemnisation pour tenir
parce que c'était c'est un impact très
fort lee a eu un impact très fort sur le
tourisme oui mais alors mais c'est parti
vous citiez tout à l'heure des chiffres
ado c'est donc à des différents plans
mais ce que nous avons dit vous allez
quand on est dans une situation de crise
majeure puisque c'est une crise majeure
dont les conséquences seront
malheureusement durables sur le plan
économique et social
nous attendions une mobilisation totale
ray quand le président de la république
au mois de mars avait dit quoi qu'il en
coûte
nous étions dans cette démarche là un
moment donné c'est à dire que l'enjeu
c'est quoi c'est pas de faire voter des
budgets supplémentaires
ce n'est pas de décréter que nous
faisons des plans de refondations des
plans d'urgence
l'enjeu c'est quoi c'est de libérer
effectivement les aides au moment où les
entreprises en ont besoin besoin nous
aurons un débat très prochainement
c'est quand même quelque chose que nous
avons du mal à entendre parce que nous
l'avions dit à l'époque
comment se fait-il que l'on peut puisse
mobilis fait voter des emprunts et ne
pas les mobiliser c'est à dire que
grosso modo nous avons la capacité
budgétaire
à faire mais que nous n'avons pas engagé
les démarches pour pouvoir obtenir que
de l'argent soit disponible au niveau
des comptes de la ctm pour le soutien à
l'économie et au social
c'est ça qui me pose problème déjà posé
la question m'a même temps pays il ya un
budget supplémentaire 2010
supplémentaires qui ont été votées et
pour autant il n'est pas complètement
mobilisé le conseiller exécutif chargé
des budgets miguel laventure disait il
ya quelques semaines que ils le seraient
au fur et à mesure des besoins réels
bon alors on a un peu de mal à
comprendre que la 7e s'endettent pour
265 millions d'euros
et puis qu'il ya peu de ses 210 à une
faible somme qui est éjecté déjà là dans
le tissu économique
vous savez la gestion du budget je
dirais les contours du budget c était
une affaire entre du président du
conseil exécutif je dirais pratiquement
exclusivement alors avec le conseiller
du budget certainement un moment donné
mais déjà je dirais on a on a déjà un
problème au départ en rappelez vous
qu'on avait donné on a eu un audit qui a
été de commander cet audit nous n'avons
aucun conseiller n'a eu cet audit on l'a
demandé à cor et à cri on l'a on la
demandait en plaignons la demande est
déjà pour savoir qu'est ce qu'il y avait
vraiment comme situation financière à la
collectivité
on n'a pas eu le dit après on a au
niveau du fonctionnement des budgets
société la chambre régionale des comptes
épingle et la couronne et quand notre
pain ont donné un avis sur l'état réel
des finances de la collectivité
territoriale
au premier tour les semailles monsieur
parti que vous commandez un audit payés
par la collectivité que vous n'ayez pas
l'audit ne sommes pas des enfants on
vous conseillera nautique pour qu'on ne
nous fournit pas l'eau dites moi si
c'est vraiment une des choses qui me
reste un petit peu sur l'estomac comme
on dit est ce que ce qui compte
le président du conseil exécutif n'a pas
fourni le dit on l'a demandé on la
demandait en plénière on l'a demandé par
écrit mon groupe et notamment monsieur
mon plaisir il a demandé à par tous les
moyens on est on est soi disant pas soi
disant on a un contrat de gestion
comme vous avez un contraste vous n'avez
pas l'audit ce n'était déjà pas normal
c'est pour vous dire que la la la
question du budget de l'utilisation du
budget de la mobilisation du budget
vraiment une question qui était vu et
traité pratiquement exclusivement par le
président du conseil exécutif et quand
vous regardez pendant toutes les années
où on a eu deux mandatures
ben nous lé conseil exécutif pour
réaliser nos actions on a des fois moi
ça m'est arrivé deux ans de suite où dès
le moi de main selon mme explique qu'il
n'ya plus de ligne de fond sur les
lignes 2 d'exécution de nos actions et
puis on voit arriver en fin octobre des
fonds et après alors on avait une
politique de stop and go qu'on ne
comprenait pas à dire mais mes essais et
c'est ce que j'aurai je dirais fortement
à reprocher c'est cette politique on ne
comprend pas donc et pour vous dire
aujourd'hui nous avons la capacité de
faire des emprunts et nous ne le faisons
pas les opérations derrière il faut
pouvoir les faire aussi les réaliser
parce que vous pouvez pas aussi
mobilisée ces opérations ne sont pas
réalisés juste une chose pour dire c'est
vrai que quand on a voulu faire les
dispositifs d'urgence
c'est vrai qu'on a pris un certain temps
pour pour les mettre en oeuvre et jeudi
un certain temps par rapport à au
fonctionnement de la septième pour moi
c'était quand même très rapide cinq mois
ce que d'habitude on fait en un an et
tout mais l'on est en mesure d'urgence
donc c'est vrai que c'est moi peut être
long mais il fallait voir aussi qu'au
niveau de la ctm on a le personnel en a
pas on a travaillé un moment avec 800
personnes sur 4200 personnes c'est ça la
réalité de la 7e tandis que vous aviez
des jambes étaient encore il était
confiné
vous avez des gens qui est en formation
il ya eu des gens qui étaient en
télétravail plus ou moins et
après vous avez une administration aussi
qui n'a pas toujours répondu comme il le
fallait mais jeudi le premier de
l'administration peut être qu'on aura
l'occasion d'en parler je pense que
c'est l'un des problèmes clés il faudra
revoir dans je dire à la prochaine
mandature
il faut qu'on ait une administration qui
soit réactive que les gens se sentent
impliqués et et si vous n'avez pas
l'administration qu'il faut vous pouvez
développer les politiques que vous
voulez vous n'y arrivez pas évidemment
pour la pub sur la partie de
l'administration il faut que ce soit
ceux des personnes qui soient considérés
et respectés
c'est très important enfin ce n'est pas
le cas par moments je peux dire que ce
n'est pas le cas savait il faut suffit
de prendre la mesure et la température
de ce qui se passe sur le plan social à
la ctm pour comprendre que nous sommes
dans une réalité extrêmement difficile
pour les salariés
dans un premier temps ensuite j'ai
écouté avec attention la main tant pis
mais je me dis mais finalement est-ce
qu'elle est encore de la majorité oui
c'est la question que j'allais bosser
mais parce qu'en fait que je sache le
conseiller exécutif en charge des
finances est de bas payés en chance donc
le mouvement auquel appartient madame
torpilles donc à un moment donné et je
crois qu'à son avis sur par le mouvement
la coalition mais bon bah je crois que
c'est la même négocié la même coalition
nous apporter et je pense que c'est ça
qui est aujourd'hui en débat à savoir
que imaginez donc des membres de la
majorité
a fortiori quand on est membre de
l'opposition nous n'avons pas accès aux
informations
il y a réellement un manque de
transparence et un manque de pas citer
je vais prendre deux exemples premier
nous sommes en train de parler de
l'emprunt peut-être que même torpiller
le chiffre nous ne savons pas la réalité
de la mobilisation de l'emprunt oui
c'est quand même c'est quand même grave
nous sommes dans une situation d'urgence
nous n'avons eu de cesse tous ensemble
de travailler pour trouver des formules
des solutions des dispositifs les
traduire en délibération et mettre ça en
oeuvre pour que lorsqu'on pose la
question
c'est tout juste si on ne renvoie pas à
notre cour de récréation dix ans mais
non mais ça ne vous regarde pas c'est la
sphère de d'un petit nombre d'éclairer à
l'exécutif ce fonctionnement est
insupportable alors en temps normal
parce que il me semble que ce que nous
avons vraiment posée depuis le premier
jour de cette mandature ne s'est jamais
démenti est ce qu'il est aujourd'hui
sans sens oui comment dire et s'en
défendent et trouve que ça ne vous
convient pas nous le disions depuis le
début de cette mandature
donc il y à une réalité et c'est ce sur
quoi je pense qu'il nous faut tous se
mobiliser c'est de dire que est ce que
nous sommes capables
lorsque le contexte l'exigent de se
départir de pratiques et de méthodes
d'un autre temps
justement la torpille vous pouvez réagir
sur ça puisque j'allais poser cette
question à savoir que comment se fait-il
qu au sein du conseil exécutif il y eu
aussi peu de l'information et de
communication d'unanimité pour aller au
plus vite le plus vite possible puisque
les entreprises souffrent l'économie
empathie une somme aura l'antique même
si la 7e il faut le dire n'est pas le
seul acteur public qui puisse aider les
entreprises puisqu'il ya les communes
les communautés d'agglomération l'état
sans oublier les fonds européens mi
journée
oui enfin juste quand même pour
reprendre un peu ce que qu'a dit le
collègue et robin nous oui je suis
toujours de 7
je dirais je suis conseiller exécutif du
mouvement bas payant chance ça ça n'a
aucun doute personne ne se pose de
questions dessus sauf c'est vrai que
quelque part on a eu abdé je dirais que
l'honnêteté de dire les difficultés que
nous avons eues
parce que alors c'est vrai que c'était
la première fois qu'on était sur une
telle mouture de deux conseillers
exécutifs et de d'assemblée c'était la
fusion en fin de compte la fusion n'a
pas vraiment lieu
on a une juxtaposition de deux
assemblées et donc on a on jeudi reste
tout ça il a fallu le construire mais la
construction n'est pas terminée et
derrière vous avez après ddd les
responsables et notamment donc le
président qui a une façon de voir les
choses une
façon je dirais d'administrer kiki qui
nous laisse nous impose cette façon donc
maintenant après il a fallu faire avec
il a fallu se positionner et nous avons
travaillé malgré tout parce que
l'essentiel pour nous c'était de
répondre à notre engagement est de
répondre à la tête de la population donc
nous avons travaillé et moi je dis
surtout moi je sais que j'ai travaillé
s'il vient ça il soutint à travailler
pour ton voit ce qui s'est passé dans le
tourisme avec un nouveau souci d'être le
touriste c'était beaucoup la croisière
ce qui a été fait avant c'était très
bien mais ce qu'a fait ensuite après
karine mousseau c'était encore mieux
elle a ouvert un peu plus à la base et
les résultats sont là aussi au niveau
tourisme a justement pendant tout ça
fait que c'est tout ça fait que nous
avons fini nous avons tenu nos
engagements nous avons travaillé comme
il faut alors concernant meygal aventure
plus tard vous brûle les lèvres c'est de
dire que c'est vrai que bien qu'elle
soit au mouvement de nous trouvons on a
eu à ddd différents faits de vue est bon
ben oui ben ne sommes pas toujours
d'accord avec ses positions ou peut-être
lui n'est pas toujours d'accord avec nos
positions donc mais on a bien vu que
monsieur miller c'est bien détaché de
monsieur marie-jeanne toujours ça change
rigide donc et monsieur milan c'était
quand même le jeu lui le chef de file de
la majorité jours oui il est toujours
mais en fait je sais plus et pas la même
majorité donc bon on fait tout ça pour
dire qu'il y a effectivement six ans
beaucoup de choses se passent mieux la
mésaventure l'occasion de venir dans
notre émission expliqué oui lévitation
et dans ses autres
oui justement vous parlez du tourisme en
parle beaucoup du tourisme en réalité le
secteur du tourisme lui-même reprises en
souffrir certes ils souffrent les
entreprises sont preneurs et salariés
des personnes qui ont investi leur
argent leur temps leur énergie et même
j'allais dire leurs espoirs
mais en réalité à l'échelle de
l'économie martiniquaise le tourisme
pèse relativement peu par rapport à
d'autres secteurs 5% de la production
intérieure brute environ 4% 7 % des
emplois salariés
est-ce que la cité elle n'en fait pas un
peu trop pour le tourisme par rapport à
d'autres secteurs l'agriculture vivrière
et nos missions par exemple l'industrie
ou encore les petites tentes peu monté
par des jeunes qui attendrait qui
attendent encore un peu plus d'audace de
la part de ces thèmes
on en fait beau on en fait beaucoup pour
le touriste parce que c'est quand même
un secteur à fort potentiel
et puis au niveau du tourisme vous avez
effectivement peut-être des hôtels
certains actes qui ont une certaine
importance mais vous avez beaucoup de
petits acteurs au talkie beaucoup de tpe
qui qui qui je dirais qu'ils vivent
grâce au tourisme donc et c'est pour ça
que nous avons consacré une certaine je
dirais une seat un certain soutien à ce
secteur là parce que il ya beaucoup de
il ya beaucoup d'activités qui dépendent
du secteur touristique
alors concernant c'est vrai que d'autres
secteurs vous parlez des start up mais
sur la partie économique c'est quand
même 16 millions d'euros qui ont été
enfin milan et je peux vous dire que je
me suis battu peut-être pendant deux ans
a demandé que le secteur numérique que
qu'on arrivait à cette transformation
numérique la lakovic 19 ans a montré que
c'était incontournable et donc de ce
fait on a je dirai tout le monde a
compris qu'il fallait y aller mais je
dis ça fait deux ans qu'on a dû y être
un petit peu plus à avancer dans dans
cette transformation numérique mais on
en a on a on en a pris conscience et
aujourd'hui quand même c'est ce sont des
actions fortes qui sont mises en place
auprès de descente paix du monde du
monde générale de l'entreprise pour
aller vers le numérique la culture et la
pêche demande aussi un soutien tout à
fait qui n'est pas forcément là
tout à fait futur regardez moi je
connais bien le problème de l'irrigation
des agriculteurs à dimanche
ben à des manches à l'irrigation sortir
des chercheurs mais je pense qu'il ya
d'autres agriculteurs on demande donc
d'avoir une économie de proximité avec
des agriculteurs qui peuvent vraiment
été donné à manger à la population mais
il faut les équiper
il faut il ya vraiment tout une
politique a fait un qui n'est pas fait
actuellement sur les marins pêcheurs ou
s'il ya une politique il ya vraiment
hattab à je dirais accompagné notamment
ces deux professions qui sont plus ou
moins papa pas trop entendu d'après
celui que c'était très souvent sinistre
est pour beaucoup de professionnels qui
ont donné leur vie là également
ça leur métier daniel robin moi je pense
que nous sommes confrontés aujourd'hui à
une réalité qui n'est pas justement
réinventer c'est à dire que aujourd'hui
quand on regarde la manière dont la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
intervient en soutien des filières on
surfe un des filières et le mot que je
prononce en fait il n'y a pas de soutien
aux filières des soutiens de l'activité
souvent se fait de façon très cloisonné
je peux pas opposer la le tourisme
l'hôtellerie la restauration à
l'agriculture et à la pêche c'est à dire
que l'enjeu au contraire c'est
d'inscrire ces filières dans une réelle
complémentarité une réelle
interdépendance et qu'il y ait un acte
économique patriotique posées par les
acteurs touristiques qui choisissent de
façon délibérée et déterminé de soutenir
les filières de production c'est ça qui
est important mais ça n'existe pas ou
pas suffisamment suffisamment pas
suffisamment parce qu'on se rend compte
aujourd'hui
alors c'est ça c'est à dire que on se
dit tiens le soutien à l'économe à
l'économie à travers le tourisme est ce
qu'on en fait assez pour le tourisme non
je pense qu'on peut pas dire que ce qui
fait au tout en faveur du tourisme soit
au détriment des autres il faudrait
faire plus et mieux pour tous parce que
c'est ça l'enjeu quand on est sur un
petit territoire comme celui de la
martinique et que l'on voit la réalité
de ce qui se passe il faut aller sur le
marché
il faut aller voir ce qui se passe nous
avons aujourd'hui des enjeux majeurs
alors je dis pas de d'autosuffisance
alimentaire pour moi c'est un
pieux mais quand même de faire en sorte
que dans le choix des consommateurs
martiniquais il y ait une part de plus
importante fête à la production locale
c'est quelque chose qui date et moi nous
avons fréquenté
quand nous étions comme plus jeune
j'avais une association mais c'était
déjà notre credo c'est à dire que de mon
point de vue l'enjeu c'est de construire
le développement économique autour de
filières intégrées structuré qui
permettent justement de contrebalancer
tout cela parce que tant qu'on va rester
sur le côté mais auquel le tourisme ceci
la croisière cela de toute façon le
tourisme vous savez quoi
ad ce qui s'est passé en fin d'année il
ya une réalité territoriale qui fait que
quand il ya des conditions favorables et
bien les touristes y viennent
voilà donc l'enjeu c'est plutôt de dire
quel type de tourisme nous voulons face
à la première j'en à partie
vous disiez daniel robin quel type de
tourisme nous voulons mais on peut
parler encore généralisé quel type
d'agriculture d'industrie
ce que je constate cependant c'est qu'il
y avait encore une fois la période de la
crise sanitaire l'a démontré que les
circuits courts ont trouvé leur place
dans le choix des consommateurs
et c'est ça qui m'intéresse regardez
c'est à dire qu'il ya une possibilité de
faire accéder directement
et je me réjouis que cela se perd dur
que ça s'inscrive dans la durée
parce que c'est ça qui était aussi
important c'est que arrêtons de
considérer que la réalité de la
distribution elle est posée telle
qu'elle a été conçue et notamment autour
de ces réalités d'hypermarchés non il ya
aujourd'hui d'autres modes alternatifs
de distribution qu'il est possible
d'envisager et je trouve formidable que
les acteurs s'en soient eux-mêmes
emparer et c'est ça la responsabilité
aussi en termes de développement sur les
grès c'est effectivement là où je
rejoins daniel robin c'est qu'il faut
effectivement revoir une stratégie
d'ensemble et cette stratégie c'est
vraiment ce que je souhaiterais demain
pouvoir construire parce que nous avons
autour des filières
vous avez donc des dif les différents
les différents acteurs et dans les
différents domaines d'activités qui
étaient régis entre eux et c'est vrai
que ça a du sens de faire cette
structuration de flir et d'avoir cette
stratégie est aussi pour avoir cette
stratégie faut se donner certains moyens
d'organisation
or au niveau de la ctm on a mais c'est
peut-être parce qu'on n'était pas trop
habitués on a trop on a mis l'économie
on a mis une partie de l'économie donc
qui m'a été attribué en compétences et
puis l'agriculture et la pêche on m'a
dit non non c'est pas dans le secteur
économique alors que ça fait partie de
l'activité
et puis après on vous dit l'économie
sociale et solidaire mais c'est pas de
l'économie
donc on a mis ça au niveau du social et
l'économie circulaire mais c'est pas
tout à fait c'est hors jeu dit il faut
vraiment un pôle économique avec cette
structuration de filières ou que tout le
monde va dire qu'il y ait vraiment je
dirais eu un objectif commun à faire que
c'est cette synergie se passe parce que
comme vous
la vie est comme l'a dit daniel roubaix
on ne peut pas effectivement plus mettre
un peu plus sur le ep à l'autre parce
que c'est effectivement il ya une
interaction et il faut tenir ça et pour
qu'on puisse faire monter l'ensemble du
territoire ensemble alors justement
quand vous vous disiez qu'il faudrait
peut-être reconsidérer différemment les
conceptions colonna du développement
économique pour pour la 7ème et comme
dans toutes les collectivités où tous
les acteurs et je me suis laissé dire
qu'il y a un projet non bruyant de plan
de refonte de l'économie ralentit nick
que la septième en tout cas certains
happy few un cercle restreint d'élus de
la ctm sont entraînés la boe
on a du mal à avoir parce que personne
ne veut nous le donner de peur quand on
croit que c'est que c'est lui ou que
c'est elle qui ne l'a qui nous l'a
transmis mais toujours est il qu'il ya
cette urgence de repenser notre économie
est ce que la ctm peut y contribuer
sérieusement
ou alors au contraire à ce qu'on ne
risque pas une fois cette crise sinon si
on monte ou en tout cas à juguler main
qu'on revienne aux réflexes et aux
habitudes intérieur de ce parti j'espère
quand même que les je dirais à la
prochaine mandature et que les prochains
candidats auront vraiment un projet de
une perspective et avec un objectif donc
et qui qu'il y aura donc peut-être un
nouveau modèle qui va qui va être
émerger proposé jeudi
non on peut pas on va pas refaire
toujours les mêmes choses année après
année et puis bon sur le plan de relance
mais je pense que effectivement soleil
brûlant oui un plan de relance
haro fondation faire le plan de relance
que sous la refondation de la martinique
disons cela comme ça dans ses ventes
mais elle devra ça devra être présenté à
l'assemblée
à la prochaine assemblée donc la
prochaine pionner en question de savate
jeu extrêmement sérieux et je je m'élève
contre ce qui est en train de se
préparer
aujourd'hui parce qu'il me semble que
quand on regarde ce qui se passe dans le
monde entier
il est révolu le temps où un petit
nombre de personnes étaient capables de
décider pour l'avenir d'un pays c'est
terminé d'abord les martiniquaises et
des martiniquais comme d'autres dans le
monde n'en veulent plus ce qui est
important c'est que nous ayons la
possibilité dans une démarche
participative et citoyenne d'associer
les forces vives de la martinique à la
réalisation de l'expression d'abord de
leurs besoins parce que en fait on ne
peut pas trop ça donne est lobé alors
mais pour s est pas fait alors pourquoi
ce que pourquoi est-ce que cela n'est
pas fait
alors qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez orica
lance le jeu souffrait c'est qu'on soit
clair quand on parle il n'y il n'existe
pas et de façon délibérée
aujourd'hui de plan de relance il n'y en
a pas le président du conseil exécutif
n'en veut pas donc il n'y en aura pas
pourquoi vous dites qu'il avait pas ce
qu'il m'a dit je ne fais que répéter ce
qu'il a été ce qui a été clairement dit
dans l'hémicycle il n'y a un plan de
refondation et je pense que c'est une
usurpation manifeste quelle est la
différence
il y en a une qui a le plan de relance
est là pour accompagner le redémarrage
d'une économie par rapport à une réalité
de crise dans laquelle nous sommes
toujours lourdement engagé et c'est
comme si on faisait l'impasse sur ce
traitement parce que encore une fois le
plan d'urgence était une chose il
fallait remédier dans l'urgence à un
certain nombre de sujets maintenant
faire redémarrer une économie sinistrée
c'est autre chose il s'agit justement de
structure et de redéfinir les règles de
redéfinir la manière dont nous allons
engager les démarches de négociation
avec l'état avec l'union européenne de
faire en sorte que nous créions des
conditions pour que les martiniquais
entre tous qu'il s'agit des acteurs des
filières
il s'agit des bénéficiaires des
politiques publiques qu'il s'agisse des
élus soient engagés dans une démarche de
co construction et ce mot aujourd'hui
n'a aucun sens dans la manière dont trop
d'élus envisage l'avenir de leur pays et
de la ctm des animaux de l'émission
marine est trempée co-construction
refondations relance toujours est il
sans se payer de mots
il ya une urgence il faut rebâtir
l'économie martiniquaise
si on est d'accord sur ce thème qu'est
ce que vous entendez par là qu'elle est
là l'accès prioritaire sur lequel il
faudrait agir
alors moi je suis au niveau de
l'économie mais c'est un ensemble de
toutes les façons alors sur le plan pour
pour juste revenir sur sur le plan de
relance mais qui prépare la refondation
a lancé vrai que c était pas assez c'est
tout
je dirais une histoire et des termes qui
sont employés c'est ce que ce qui est
détermine ce qui devra être proposé donc
au à l'assemblée donc aux différents
élus de l'assemblée donc dans leurs
commissions ils devront discuter et
après ils vont voir si ce sera amendé ou
pas en assemblée plénière
mais je dis c'est on reste là sûr et
c'est pour ça que je moi je dis c'est
plutôt un plan de relance parce que
c'est ce sont des actions qui sont
amenés sur les deux ans qui viennent et
a hobo de ces deux ans on voit ce que
l'on fait donc il faut il faut rebâtir
un peu les folles et il est papa les
fondations mais faut il faut la relancer
l'activité
parce que une fois de plus des
entreprises ne vivent pas de subventions
mais d'activité donc il faut relancer
l'activité
et quand on a relancé cette activité et
profiter après donc de cette relance
pour pouvoir refonder si l'on souhaite
refonder
mais je pense que il faut il faut voir
les choses globalement et il faut le
voir les choses globalement mais en les
organisant et que ce soit à dire que on
voit bien que quand on prend par exemple
des mesures comme sur l'habitation la
réhabilitation de l'habitat
quand on se dit à ce moment là qu'on va
voir fait une action sur les fosses
septiques ou de demander aux gens de
faire du photovoltaïque ou bien encore
de faire de la récupération doux depuis
toutes ses activités tout tout ce
comportement entraînera de l'activité
pour nos artisans et tout mais en même
temps ça fait du bien à l'environnement
ça fait du bien à la consommation de co2
ça fait du bien à tous
donc c'est pour ça que tout est lié et
c'est pour ça qu'un programme donc dans
les prochaines je dirais les prochains
mois un programme droit prendre en
compte toutes les composantes que ce
soit économique que ce soit sociale que
ce soit de l'aménagement que ce soit de
l'équipement est aussi ensemble donc
dans la co construction
même question pour gagner l'euro mais
qui va terminer cette émission avec nous
aujourd'hui l'ex prioritaire sous
laquelle il faudrait d'abord je trouve
qu'ils ne s'abîment actionné il faut
vraiment avoir une vision claire de la
martinique dans le monde
c'est fondamental il ya deux axes qui
sont clés combattre les inégalités et
l'injustice sociale et développer le
pays par l'innovation
en deux mots il ya quelque chose qui est
quand même extraordinaire c'est que nous
avons et la crise le démontre à travers
tout ce qui est gestion des transitions
numérique énergétiques écologiques et
même climatique
puisqu'on le voit avec un certain nombre
de problèmes comme celui de l'eau il y à
des gisements de restructuration mais il
faut être dans l'innovation
ensuite je pense que le rendez vous sur
lequel nous avons tous échoué oui c'est
celui de l'emploi et singulièrement de
l'emploi des jeunes donc à travers cela
nous avons incontestablement à nous
réinventer et à faire une nouvelle offre
en fait de vision en termes de projet de
société dans lequel l'économie ne serait
plus une variable finalement mais serait
vraiment une épine dorsale adossés et je
le dis à une réalité de vraiment
combattre les inégalités et l'injustice
sociale et ainsi daniel robin conseiller
à l'assemblée des martiniquais un membre
de l'opposition de la coalition sopi
karting de progrès qui avaient discuté
aujourd'hui dans un débat civil avec une
membre de la majorité
membre du conseil exécutif marinette
tant pis chargé des affaires aux
économique c'est ainsi que se termine
notre émission de quelques instants ce
sera le journal de la rédaction de
martinique la première notre programme
été réalisée aujourd'hui par patrice à
la glisse à la chirurgie calixte je vous
donne rendez vous dimanche prochain
et puis un petit mot pour bouter mission
on nous prend nous vend avant novembre
en nous dans la langue officielle
une traduction suggéré par un ami qu aux
listes il faut savoir prendre le taureau
par les cornes
à bientôt la première
[Musique]